and we have a guest guys I thought we're
gonna get David so I'm like get dude
because I'll be gonna be real dude like
I'm gonna be completely real that gave
it so David so is a fat funny Korean guy
know him love him love him riot jolly
God I have it yeah now if you take 50
pounds away from that body right you get
this piece of [ __ ] I know now look at
what you look like a person but you look
too human [ __ ] human being now I
don't want you to look human do it I
like the way you were
Kelly I know my knees are shot and your
fat wonder this guy here - babe you
working a bobo factory oh you had the
baby yourself is that what happened you
[ __ ] you look gross man get your [ __ ]
together man so David so what was the
last time you were here nice been a
minute like six I'll get orbble with me
- I'll get her back down y'all may get
urban back down there you feel really a
company I always talk I know but you
know Dwight it up bro okay I'm Wyatt bro
it's been quite a while thank you year
yes we've seen you and through your
Instagram I've been watching it and I've
been seeing that you're losing weight
you have a girlfriend
yes what's her name Muriel Muriel yeah
my dog house Mario she's good she's good
yeah it's this she likes that skinny or
David yeah this guy's kind of [ __ ]
annoying though you know because like
she uh like the other day because we
don't see each other every day so we see
each other about once or twice a week so
every week I'm losing a little bit of
weight so the other day she came over
and I opened the door and she goes who's
that uh it's me you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] you see me consistently
losing yeah so for every time yeah just
so you can actually see like real change
yeah
are you getting better roll it what
you're losing it no aside from being
healthy are you doing it to make it in
Hollywood I don't get
oh no I'm that on ice right now so I'm
not really doing the whole acting thing
I'm doing the writing thing right now
so whoa so you're doing the whole
[ __ ] uh JJ Abrams in a clock have
been writing a [ __ ] script kind of no
I'm doing that in my room but what are
you writing Dave right now I'm trying to
sell something for vertical platforms
instead of just regular TV so oh it's so
something for like what Facebook and
scramblers anybody else I feel like
that's gonna be the next thing so whoa
that's TV show you think maybe yeah no
one even maybe you're driving right yeah
I mean it really depends I mean I feel
like just from yeah I mean we kind of
like made it out to be so ah it's gold
it can go to TV this is cut the bias we
can make it vertical whew I want to cut
the chase let's do it
am I gonna be in it of course I'm gonna
tell you right now friend all right I'm
sick and tired of this [ __ ]
I'm sick at are you Aquafina your Jimmy
O yang you David so you young cats man
right coming up in the world right and
you don't kill [ __ ] Uncle Bob no love
I always give I need a [ __ ] I need a
[ __ ] paycheck wrong I need a paycheck
clothes on and [ __ ] going on an
audition then an ass okay all right so
you you you you got something for Uncle
Bob if I get dude I'll do what I want to
play okay here's what I want I don't
want to move much right so I don't want
to mark you know how you know when
you're on a set you have to have a mark
yeah I don't want any mark because I
don't move the cameras come to me no I
don't want to move on Oh Alba does I'm
handicapped I'm in a wheelchair but also
a shut-in perfect right I don't want to
move over in or out of a room outside he
doesn't want sunlight I'm in a room I am
in a wheelchair right I don't want to
memorize nothing say nothing
but I want to be second lead you could
just do a voiceover for a CG overweight
cat I want to be in it you will you know
I know what my say is to be in it I want
an eternal cartoon
when I think our zoo is wrong the cats
look like just like hey you know what
we'll see about it we'll see because I'm
gonna say this right and am I gonna name
any names but I've helped out a lot of
cats in my in my career like actual cats
yeah three no not like cats but like
humans in showbiz and they've all made
it no don't do that babe I'm surprised
you haven't written something you have
such a while yeah I'm sorry I'm on a TV
show right now yeah but you know I I
don't have time right now yeah I agree
okay when Papa has the time
Papa will do okay
[Music]